what's happening people the project that
me and James Smith have been working on
for the last 12 months is finally going
live one week today on Friday November
the 3D it has taken so long and we have
nearly killed each other there have been
many ups and downs and a ton of problems
issues that we encountered and then
finally Victory which we're about to
show you it is the most amount of money
I've ever put into a project it is the
longest I've ever spent designing and
building something and I can't wait to
show you over the next week you're going
to see stories of how it all came
together behind the scenes stuff there's
going to be teaser images and a ton more
so yeah get ready the next week is going
to be filled with us releasing all
different pieces and then one week today
you're finally going to get to see what
it is all right I can't wait to show you
this peace